so you've made it to the final set of
trials it may feel like you've gone
through hell and back just to get here
but baby you ain't seen nothing yet if
you are just now jumping into the master
sword trials check out our beginner tips
video Dave will walk you through the
basics but if you've already finished
the first two challenges
get ready for some elemental Tallis's
truckloads of Guardians tons of mob
lands and of course [ __ ]
Lionel's
the last set of trials can be
overwhelming but we are gonna break it
down floor by floor and with a lot of
inventory management and a little luck
you should be able to make it to the end
the majority of these trials focus on
weather and elemental challenges this
makes dealing with enemies slightly more
difficult but as long as you prepare
appropriately they shouldn't cause too
much trouble when you first enter the
final trouser you're greeted with a
thunderstorm
don't equip metal weapons and keep your
distance from the lightning and this
shouldn't be much of a problem and since
most of the enemies you will be fighting
our skeletons there are no shortage of
bone weapons because your competition on
these first five floors are mostly
skeletons they aren't too hard to deal
with
once you've knocked the head off the
body with a well-placed bomb just hit
the head once and it's dead
like actually dead
just because these floors are easy
doesn't mean you shouldn't be on the
lookout for equipment one of the best
swords you can find in the final trials
is on the second floor to the left of
the skeleton fort is a buried chest use
mag nice is to pop that sucker out of
the ground and look inside to find a
Royal Guard sword with an attack rating
of 48 nice even though these aren't too
hard the fourth floor might give you
some trouble I start out by throwing a
bomb into the pack of bull cob lens on
horseback once they've been dealt with
hop on a horse and clear out the rest
but be wary of the skeleton mob 'ln with
electric arrows I would recommend
leaping off your horse and slowing down
time in order to take this sucker out if
you don't he can be a pain in the ass
the fifth floor is the boss floor the
stall Knox isn't too bad use stasis on
him and aim for the eye if you've made
it this far in the trials he should be a
walk in the park
once you slay him make sure to grab the
great frost blade the flame spear and
the Thunder sword these will make your
life much easier moving forward next up
is a rest area but before you do
anything else sneak over and grab the
ferry now open up the chests and make
sure to equip the flame breaker boots
you should also get your first set of
ancient arrows as tempting as it may be
to use these let's hold on to them for
now cook some food smash some boxes and
when you ready step on to the
teleportation pad things are about to
start heating up if you have the flame
breaker boots equipped the heat won't be
much of an issue and again these first
few floors aren't too difficult
the lizalfos can be annoying but one
strike from the great frost blade should
put them out of commission
on floor 9 you'll come across a few
lizalfos and a fire wizzrobe use your
frost grade sword to kill them in one
hit and make sure to grab the meteor rod
from the wizzrobe once again let's hold
on to this guy for now next important
thing you want to hit is on floor 10
after you've cleared out the enemies
pull out mag Nice's and fish out this
chest that should net you three more
ancient arrows now the second boss is a
little more tough but if you're great
frost blade is still in good shape you
shouldn't have much trouble use the
frost blade to cool off the Beast
climates back and Hackett's exposed or
with a sword rinse and repeat until the
talus is dead now don't move there are
two fairies in this room crouch and
sneak up to them after that I'd
recommend cooking up some heat-resistant
meals but you know the drill by now
once you're ready to hit the teleporter
equip your flame spear now as long as
you have the flame spear equipped you
shouldn't have to worry about the cold
but I would use it sparingly not only
will this protect you against the cold
but it also kills lizalfos and Wiz robes
in one hit once again these first few
floors aren't too demanding something
else to note is that on the 13th floor
there is a cooking pot and the boxes
next to it have some meat I would
recommend cooking that meat before
heading out and gathering some firewood
throughout these next few floors you'll
find ice blocks that obscure treasure
chests there are a couple ways to melt
these without burning through too many
resources you can one start a campfire
near them or two you can hold a fire
arrow over them it may take a while but
the reward is well worth it especially
on the 14th floor melting the block to
the right of the start yields three more
Guardian arrows trust me you'll need
these
time for the boss floor hopefully you
still have the flame spear the meteor
rod or enough fire arrows to deal with
the ice talus follow the same strategy
as before and you should be on your way
to the safe room wait nope never mind
King Lionel if you're feeling confident
you can take them on if you want as gear
but I don't like to mess with this guy
so I typically send him into another
dimension with the help of an ancient
arrow
adios bag safe room take your time to
refuel because the real challenge is
about to begin if you don't know how to
deflect a guardian beam now's the time
to learn lock onto the Guardian hold
your shield up and when you hear the
final beep hit a to deflect here's the
sound one more time just in case you
missed it if you timed it right it's a
one-hit kill if you didn't well your
journey might be over the first floor of
this set puts you in the middle of a ton
of stationary Guardians only one will
activate it first but as you kill more
more will light up however you can
manually activate a guardian by hitting
it stick to the edges of the floor and
activate one at a time while using trees
as protection this is also where I burn
through most of my fairies and shields
if you get overwhelmed near the end use
a Guardian arrow or two but don't go
crazy cuz you're gonna need those the
next floor pits you against one mobile
guardian the quickest way to take care
of this guy apart from using an ancient
arrow is deflecting its attacks with
your shield after three successful
counters the machine will die and it's
on to the next floor now it's time to
take on a flying guardian hopefully you
have bomb arrows but if not there's a
chest on top of the center pillar that
has Sun try to get above the Guardian
and drop down once you're underneath it
aim for the bottom of its engines with
your bomb arrow now that the engines are
destroyed the guardian should come
falling down and it's useless it's kind
of sad to be honest
[Music]
welcome to floor 22 aka the guardian
party there's a guardian skywatcher a
guardian stalker and a guardian turret
first I'd run for cover in the castle
open the chests and target the sky
watcher use your bomb arrows to take out
the propellers and finish it off on the
ground then idler the stalker away from
the turrets line-of-sight and deflect it
to beam three times finally sink some
arrows into the eye of the turret or if
you're sick of Guardians just use an
ancient arrow but make sure you have one
left after you've looted the area get
ready for the final challenge and it all
comes down to this this floor can be
overwhelming but now isn't the time to
panic you're looking at about nine book
hablas on horseback
a guardian turret and of course a Lionel
let's deal with the lionel first
equipment ancient arrow and send him to
space next up let's deal with the book
goblins but you'll need to get some air
in order to avoid the Guardian turret
set some grass on fire and take to the
skies start picking off the book
hobbling while keeping your distance
from the turret after that finish off
the turret and let out a huge sigh of
relief try it with me now and that's it
you've made it to the very end it's time
to pat yourself on the back and test out
your supercharged Master Sword if you
want to see that baby in action head on
over to our YouTube channel and for more
on Zelda consider subscribing it really
helps us out thank you
[Music]